[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's
God. It's God.
Whether this man study the Bible because
online to Muslims, if any Muslim can
prove to me that Jesus is a
Muslim,000. So we have
$1,000. How much?
$1,000. All
right.
Logic logic.
Before I give you Bible
lessons, I want to find out he's going
to go this man.
study division.
[Applause]
Liar who has passed the test who had
become your liar. Come
on. Don't waste my time. That's what
they
do. Cook
me. Wait.
What about
the
wash? What about the wash? You have to
wash all of this. I'll bring
my I'll bring my
Bibles,000. We're going to test
you. You're panicking. No, no, no, no,
no. Don't go there. Test. He's on your
way.
No, no, no, no, no, no. We come to that
test. No, no, no. This is £1,000
challenge. I'm going to take the
testable first of
all, run
away. If you if you pass the test for
the test. All right. So, we got Are you
ready for the test, you guys? Ladies and
gentlemen, £1,000. We got topics here
and we I came all the way to London. One
to find the NGO. What is it? We're still
finding it. I'm trying to ask what it
is.
The second thing, hold on. The other
thing is, ladies and gentlemen, is that
I came here to see if any of this could
be answered. to change if they can
change my mind on anything. Paul is
greater than Muhammad. Do you all agree?
Okay. We got I don't believe that Allah
is all powerful. What do y'all think?
No. Okay.
The Trinity is true. What y'all think
about that?
And the Quran confirms the Bible. Okay.
I want my mind to be changed on anything
on these topics. Brothers, can you can
you tell me? I will deal with them if he
can prove to me that he has studied the
Bible and not
how he get the money. No,
he answer the question. Answer the
question first and then we'll answer the
Bible. Answer his question first and
then the
Bible. He was standing there. You came
to the Bible. Yeah, we going to do this
first. Have you? We going to do this
first. I studied the original Quran
before I got corrupt. He's panicking. I
studied the original Quran. When I come
here, Paul is greater than Muhammad.
Change my mind. Change my mind. Paul
is belong to people. I will study your
Let's do it right now.
passible and I'm going to pass the test
in all from the Bible questions. You're
a wimp.
I'll debate with you any topic. Let's do
it. Paul is greater
than Paul is greater than Muhammad.
That's all answer
questions. Wait, wait,
wait. If you don't want to take the
test, if you don't want to take what you
don't want to take the test because I
never wish for the Bible, let's debate
concept of God in
Islam. That's
okay. That's okay. That's okay. I mean,
that's okay. Concept of God is funny.
That's okay. I said that's okay.
Have you sold your Bible? Say yes. You
have concept of God in Islam in the
Bible. Have you Bible? Yes. You have you
have for you,000 after you know you lost
money.
So talk about the concept of God in
Christianity versus Islam.
You got the timer going? Yeah. the
concept of God in Christianity versus
Islam. Um, and I believe that the
concept of God in Islam doesn't make any
lick of sense. Um, even if you could
show me that Allah is one one. Um, if
you say that Allah is one God, does that
mean he's only one person? You got to
show that. Show me that in the Quran cuz
he says we and us a lot and our a lot. I
don't know what that means. Roy,
majesty, I don't know. Um, but then you
have a lot of problems when it comes to
the concept of God in Islam with him
having certain titles that belong to
himself or certain attributes or actions
that I see that are applied to others.
10 seconds. So, for example, we're going
to get into this. We're going to see if
Allah alone has these attributes. And if
he doesn't, then that means he has
multiple gods in Islam.
All right, let's go.
Are
you so see 1 minute is not enough but
I'm going to speak very fast. Look the
person of God in Islam very clear. We
the Muslim worship Allah the creator not
the creation. Allah created everything.
We believe in all the prophets and we do
not make any distinction with any of the
prophets. Muslims we believe in Isaam.
He was the Messiah sent to the children
of Israel. He never said he's God. He
never said worship me. He didn't show me
why Jesus said I am God. What does it
mean? I become a Christian. If you can
show me the word Bible in the Bible, I
become a Christian. If you can show me
the word Christianity in the Bible, I
become a Christian. Now, run as 14
before I come to the Bible to be banking
140 suras. If you know about the god in
Islam, you go to 112 surah. I should be
very fast. You see, 1 minute enough.
Yes, it is. 2 minutes. All right. Time.
All right. Time. Time.
Time. Okay. Ready? Uh-huh. All right.
So, he says if he can show me where
Jesus says in the exact words, I'm God.
Worship me. He'll become a Christian.
All right. Fine. And I'll become a
Muslim. If he shows me where Jesus says,
I am not God. Do not worship me in those
exact words. I'll become a Muslim. Okay?
Since we're using that type of tactic
here, showing you how dumb this argument
is. Okay? That's one. Number two, he
says, "We Muslims, we worship the
creator. Allah created everything.
Uh-uh. There's actually one thing he
didn't create. There's a little bird
over there that was flying out that
Allah didn't create. Guess who created
it? Jesus. Jesus. So, how many creators
do you have in Islam? Two. You got two
creators. So, Allah didn't create
everything. There's one thing he didn't
create. He helped Jesus create a bird.
So, when that bird is singing out tweet,
tweet, tweet, it's singing thank you
Jesus and thank you Allah for creating
me. So it's worshiping Allah and Jesus.
So why do you got two creators in Islam?
Do you have two gods?
I go to Bible now straight away. I'm
sorry Bible now. The God of Abraham, the
God of Isaac. Very clear to the children
of Israel. There is one God. He's a
savior. He's not a man. Fully God, fully
man. He can't show me. You go to your
Bible in the book of
Isaiah chapter number 43. Are you all
laughing? Thank you. Before me, no
stone. No, there be one after me. I am
the Lord besides me. There's no savior.
Exactly. Deuteronomy
6:45. Here is why. The Lord our God, the
Lord is one. You know Jesus said the
same thing. Same thing in the New
Testament in Gospel of Mark
129. Here is one. The Lord our God and
Lord is one. Not only one.
Jesus said, "Worship the Lord your God
and serve only him." You worshiping him.
Why do you worship Jesus? Gospel of
Matthew. Go for the Bible. Matthew 10.
Matthew 4:10. Worship the Lord your God
and serve only him. Same message is
repeated in Luke 4:8. Worship the Lord
your God and serve only him. Why was
Jesus? No. Go to the Bible. Time. Go for
the Bible. You can't. I'll give you
Bible message. Don't go. I go to the Old
Testament, too.
I'm waiting. Yeah. All right. It's me.
It's me. All right. So, we didn't get a
question on why there's two creators in
Islam. He says he has one God, but
there's multiple creators. So, either
Jesus is one with Allah and there's
still one God. He's just two persons. Or
you got two gods, Jesus and Allah, who
are separate. You got to answer that. I
got to deal with that. Now, I'm I quote
a Quran. He don't want a Quran. I show
him Quran. He doesn't want Quran. I show
him Quran. He doesn't want corrupt.
Okay. Well, let's go to the Bible. Now,
in the Bible, he quoted it Mark 12,
right? Where Jesus says, "There's only
one God, right? Here is the Lord our
God, the Lord is one." Now, we keep
reading. This is what Jesus also says.
When we go down to verse 35, he says,
"Who son is the Messiah?" They say, "The
son of David." Well, he says, "How is he
the son of David?" When David says, "The
Lord said to my Lord, sit at my right
hand until I make your enemies your
fuss." So Jesus says that he's the Lord,
the Lord of David, the Lord of you, the
Lord of every prophet, who sits at the
right hand of of of Yahweh the father.
Explain that. I'm going to
start Jesus is sitting at the right hand
of
God. He cannot be God. How? Let's go to
Bible. God of Old Testament made it
clear.
You got one more. You got one more
minute. One more. No. You can destroy
him. No. I just got him a present. I
went to Hley. I bought him a present.
Please. I swear to God. I got him a
present. I wrapped it up myself. I swear
to God. They asked me, he said, "What
age is it for a three-year-old?" I'm
waiting for
it. Soft. He's very
soft. So, brother, you start.
All right. Go on. The next one. Yeah.
I'm going to put the Quran. I'm going to
read the Quran. The Quran. Quran now.
I'm starting now. Start now. Yeah. Go.
You
said2 blasphemy that is
belief of madam is Allah his almighty
god said Christ Jesus said all children
is
worship my lord and your
lord anyone
who Allah will make paradise for
forbidding for the person
answer and we read for and no help. So I
want to quote Quran and come to the
Bible again. 10 seconds 1 minute is not
enough. Okay. Yeah. For the Bible. All
right. So notice ladies and gentlemen, I
responded to multiple claims of lame. He
hasn't responded to not one of mine. He
haven't answer. You haven't responded to
Jesus creating the burden. So you have
two creators in Islam. So your concept
of God is messed up. I responded to you
about Mark 12 and you still didn't
respond to me with my response to you.
So when Jesus is sitting at the right
hand of the father, why is this
significant? Because in Psalm 83:18, it
says, "You Yahweh are the alone most
high who sits on high." So Jesus says
that he sits on high with the father,
making him most high along with the
father. That's why this is significant.
So Jesus is claiming that he's lord of
the prophets who sits on high along with
the father making him equal with the
father in his essence. That's tr that's
uh Christianity and that's the bible in
context. What you need to do is tell me
why in the world will a bird have to wor
how many I mean how many people will the
wor the bird have to worship. Will the
bird be giving thanks to Allah alone or
will the bird be also giving thanks to
Jesus as well? time Quran Quran you know
that's why I say you lie about your
Bible you lie about the Quran there alan
3 uh verse number 49 can I read it and
Jesus will make and Allah will make him
a messenger to the children of Israel
who will say indeed I have come to you
with a sign from your lord that I
designed for you from clay like the form
of a bird then I breathe into it and it
becomes a bird by Allah's permission
Yeah. And when you go to the Bible,
Bible lessons, when you go to the Bible,
Acts 2:22, when Jesus left this world,
Peter, the right hand man of Jesus,
maybe Peter knew that because of the
miracles Jesus was performing, people
were they inclined to worship him. No,
he said he took the disciples to address
a crowd said, "Oh men of Israel, hear
these words Jesus of Nazareth. A man, a
man attested you by God with mighty
works and wonders and threatening."
Yeah. Any of you just who did the job?
God, not Jesus.
All right. You lie about the Quran. God.
All right. I'm going to expose you. He
said I lied. I didn't lie. He called it
exactly what I said. Now you're
interrupting me. Please don't interrupt
me. Come on. I'ming you. Okay. All
right. So, it becomes a living bird by
Allah's permission. Nice. So, by the
permission of Allah, you have two
creators. You still didn't get around
that. So by the permission of Allah, he
gave Jesus permission to create. Not the
ability. Those are two different things.
If I give you, for example, let's say
I'm a general. I'm your general. You're
my you're my sniper, right? You don't
take the shot unless I give you
permission to take the shot. That
doesn't mean I gave you ability to
shoot. You already have that, right? So
I gave you permission to shoot, right?
So So, so Jesus already has the ability
to create. He just does it when Allah
gives him permission. You still got two
creators. Okay. So, so why is the bird
Why is the bird singing tweet tweet
worshiping Allah and Jesus? He's going
to thank two people Allah and Jesus for
his existence. Please deal with that.
That's why I said look now the Bible
saying you only time I said Allah's
permission quoted act 2:22. What did
Peter said? You know the verse quot he
doesn't
know. I quot it.
Because to quote it, you don't know. You
need the Old Testament. Almighty God,
the God of Abraham, as of Jacob, the God
of all the prophet. Know what he said?
Isaiah
44:24. I am the Lord who made all things
who alone straight out the heavens
who know Jesus there. Come on, bro. You
need the Bible. Isaiah 45:18. For this
is what the Lord says. For this is what
our Lord says. He who he who created the
heaven is God. He first he founded it.
That's it. Bro, I'm giving Bible lessons
in your life. Go, don't run away. I' got
about 20 buses.
Go answer the
question. No way,
man. Focus. Focus.
Go. I'm focusing.
So again, no response to why the bird is
going to be thinking. Come on, let me
give it to you back.
Come on, bro. It's all good. All
right.
So So no response. No response to Jes uh
to why Jesus is also a creator by
Allah's permission. You still have two
creators. Say bye-bye.
Bye-bye. There's no tawed is done now.
Now I'll go to the Bible for you now. So
I'm going to respond to another claim of
yours. In Isaiah, it talks about how
Yahweh creates by himself. Why? There's
only one God who is Yahweh. This one God
who's Yahweh exists as multiple persons.
For example, you got Genesis 19:24.
Yahweh rained down Sodom and Gomorra so
from fire Sodom and Gomorrah from Yahweh
out of heaven. Two persons. Yahweh says,
"Let us make man in our image, multiple
persons." And Yahweh also says, "Now
Yahweh has sent me and his spirit."
Three persons there in Isaiah 48:16. Can
you talk about that?
I've been quoting verses to you. You can
deal with them. You ask me question.
Look, I
look I didn't ask any question. I can
ask you question. Almighty God in the
Old Testament said he's the only
creator. Jesus never said he's God.
Never said he. Align the Quran
according you can't is there not a
single verse you are going going to
obscure verses you know what Jesus said
Jesus said let me Jesus let me let
me you read the Bible You're
not
back. He's gone. He's gone. He's
gone. He's
empty. Exactly.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Chapter number 20
verse number
14. Indeed I am Allah. There is no
deity. There is no God except me. So
worship me and establish prayer for my
remembrance. When I got the Bible, the
Old Testament, God of Abraham, Isa,
Jacob, the God of all the prophets, many
clear is God. He's the creator. Now if
you think Jesus is God, show me in the
Bible why Jesus said he created a a
fly everything. All right. So so he said
that God is God because he's the creator
right God is God because he's the
creator. So by your standard since Jesus
is also a creator. What is he? He's God.
By
following I'm telling you I'm telling
you man see you got to deal with that.
So look, I I I don't care how you want
to do it. If you want to say that that
Jesus is a creator because of Allah's
permission, if you're saying that Jesus
is a creator because of Allah's
permission, then therefore you got two
gods. Now, unless you want to say that
Jesus and Allah are one. What does that
sound like to y'all? John 10:30. I and
the father are one in context of being
in one in essence, not in just in
purpose, but in essence with the father.
Yes, sir. Okay. How much? Oh, I got 10.
Okay, so you wanted a verse where Jesus
is created, right? Colossians 1 16. It
says, "For by him all things are created
in heaven or on earth." Who said that?
Deal with that time. Do you know who
said that? That's what the Bible
versible.
What did Jesus himself? The master
himself said.
No, no, no. What you're doing is not
fair. But he was
saying him. Yeah, guys. Nobody. Nobody
gone. Who you believe in as a messiah?
No. Muslim is a Muslim. If you don't if
you don't believe in Jesus Christ, any
Muslim who doesn't believe Jesus, the
Messiah, you are taking us out of the
Islam, the Messiah may be clear in the
Bible. John 20:17, he said to Mary
Magdalene, touch me not for I am not yet
ascended to the father, but go to my
brethren and say to them, I'm ascending
to my father and your father, to my God
and your God. John 8:40 Jesus said to
his enemies, "But now you seek to kill
me, a man who has told you the truth
which I have from God." Distinction.
John 8:42. If God were your father, you
love me. So I have come here from God. I
have not come on my own. God sent me. If
Jesus is God who sent Jesus, deal with
that man. Read your Bible, bro. Your
honor on honor. That's why I gave you
the man,000 challenge. You run away from
me like a chicken. £00.
He run away like a chicken had a week.
Time we study your Bible. Go your fake
robe. I'm quoting from your Bible, not
Quran. Ask question for the Bible. So
notice he he boom. So he quoted it from
Isaiah. I gave him verses from Isaiah.
No answer. I quoted his Quran. No
answer. Nothing about the Quran. No
responses to him. Just more like
filibuster. But when I give you verses,
you don't respond to what I'm what I'm
talk telling you about. You get no
responses to the verses. Now, let's talk
about this. Then you talked about John
8, right? Where he says that when uh uh
you're trying to seek you seek to kill
me, a man who's given you the truth from
God, right? But he didn't finish the
verse. Jesus continues to say, "Abraham
did not do this." Hold on a second.
Jesus, when did Abraham have an
opportunity to kill you when you came to
him? Huh? When when was that? When did
Jesus come to Abraham? And Abraham had
an opportunity to kill Jesus or reject
him. Abraham didn't try to kill Jesus.
So Jesus is saying that he pre-existed.
He visited Abraham and visited him and
Abraham listened to him. Abraham didn't
try to kill him. You keep proving my
point. Please answer that directly.
Talk. I want you to talk about that.
Brother, stop. You're feeling miserable.
You go to obscure buses. Emptic buses
are there.
[Applause]
Paul, you're not giving my point. Just
relax. I'm I'm waiting for you. You
going say Jesus only. What did he say?
No, you read the Bible. Even Paul Paul
was not a trutharian. 1 Timothy 2:5. For
there is one God. For there is one God
and one mediator between God and
mankind. The man Christ Jesus. The
man. You need You need the Bible.
1 Corinthians
8:6 Corinthians 8:6 For us for us there
is one God which is the father from whom
all things came and for whom we live and
one lord
who Jesus yeah but who is God there
everything comes from who come on you
give Bible lessons and
here is still here I can test you
Time. You haven't studied your Bible.
Yeah, I've been waiting for this. Last
year you came, I was in here time, bro.
Next week. Next week.
Okay. So, he quoted 1 Corinthians 8:6.
It says, "For unto us there's one God
the Father from whom are all things."
And then it says, "And one Lord, Jesus
Christ, through whom are all things." He
literally went to a verse that proves
the deity of Christ along with the
father being the one Lord through whom
are all things. If all things are
through Jesus, that means that he always
existed. He's not created. He's the
creator along with the father. Lamine.
So, so Lame, thank you again for
continuing to prove my point. I want you
to do this with I want you to do me this
favor. I look everything that you're
quoting, I'm showing how it backfires
against you. Everything you're quoting,
it debunks you. You're helping me.
You're helping my case. What I need you
to do is tell me, why do you have why do
you have two creators in Islam? Can you
answer that,
brother? Brother, look this guy here.
He's a
comedian in the Quran. Look, have you
read the Quran? Answer the question.
What question?
All right.
614. Yeah.
Say tell them salute for ourselves.
Anybody anybody apart from Allah as our
creator when he is the creator of the
heavens and the earth. What are you?
when you see who feeds but it's not fed
no Muslim will tell you that we are two
creators we worship Allah only one I
mean anybody even even my my neighbor
going to laugh at you who read the Quran
he's a Christian you see what I mean
deal with the case yeah you cannot prove
to me you'll be on and on Jesus is God
yeah why show me the verse why Jesus
says God why I said worship me it's not
there why I said creator Jesus said
is the Lord of the heavens and the
earth.
You're wasting my time now.
All right. He said that nobody said, no
Muslim says that there's two creators.
Now, the reason why I would say y'all
probably don't say that is cuz you don't
like your Quran. You don't read cuz
according to your Quran, there's more
than one creator. Matter of fact, Allah
says that he's the best. He's the best
of the
creators plural. You got multiple
creators in Islam. One of them being
Jesus, another one being the Rook who
created the boy and gave Mary the boy
that she gave birth to. You got multiple
creators in Islam. Allah's just the best
of them. Okay. Matter of fact, anybody
can vote view my streams. You we we
literally got Muslims admitting that
yes, there's two creators, but what's
wrong with that? You got Muslims saying
that. Are they not Muslims? Probably
not. Huh? What you need to answer is
Jesus. Now, you're saying that they're
all the only creator. So my question to
you is very simply did Jesus create the
bird with the help of Allah? Did he
create the bird by Allah's permission?
And if so, if yes, how many creators is
that? It's a good time. You're not I
think you're wasting my time. I quoting
the Quran from the Bible. You can show
me the Bible. So you go of Abraham as
God of all the prophets say he's the
creator. Jesus said in uh uh gospel of
Matthew 11:25 he said I praise you
father lord of the heavens and the earth
no trinity there no you can't deal with
it go to your instead of asking question
go to your bible and show me a proof you
can't go
11:9 for I am God and man in the book of
exodus 22-5 you shall have no god
besides me he shall not make for
yourself a graven image or any likeness
or anything that is in heaven above or
that is in the army or that is in the
water onto the earth. You shall not bow
down to or to serve them for I the Lord
your God and a jealous God. God said in
your Bible and you go against your Paul
is by with the name of by name of Jesus
heaven is above in heaven. Paul is
saying that Philippians 2:10 quot you
can prove it time online about the
Quran. All right. Don't go to Quran.
Prove it. All right. Here we go.
So he caught in Matthew 11. You guys see
what I keep doing? I keep using the
verses that he uses in the context that
destroys him. In Matthew 11, Jesus says,
"I thank you, Father, Lord of heaven and
earth." He continues and he says in
verse 27, "All things that the father
has are mine." What does the What does
the father have? The stars, the heavens,
the earth, you, me, the birds, all of
creation belongs to the father and to
Jesus. according to the passage he went
to. So according to his passage, Jesus
is God along with the father. And guess
what he also says? No one knows the
father except the son and no one knows
the son except the father. Wait a
second, Jesus. Stop that. You can't say
that. You can't say that. Because to
know God, your mind has to be infinite.
And Jesus says he has an infinite mind.
And to know Jesus, it takes an infinite
mind. That's why only the father knows
Jesus. So explain us to me. I I forget
everything. Explain that to me. Why is
everything that belongs to the father
belongs to Jesus as well? All right. All
right. Why is it that in the Bible?
You want to
ask throughout the Bible Jesus
throughout the Bible Jesus makes a
distinction between him and the father
between him and God. Several verses I
quoted here. I can quote more. Look,
even when according to uh uh the the
Bible when Jesus was being crucified in
the gospel of uh Matthew chapter number
27 verse number 46, he
said, "Oh my God, oh my God, why has
thou forsaken
me? You
understand as I said John 42 again, my
father is greater than I. Why is it for
equality?" In 1 Corinthians 11:3, the
head of Christ is God. Who is God? You
should deal with that. The Bible, the
head of Christ is God. Deal with
that. Who is God? Who is Jesus there?
The head of Christ is God. Deal with
those
verses. I'm going to
go. Alhamdulillah. Go.
All right. Hey guys.
Hey guys. Anywhere you go.
So ladies and gentlemen, do you guys see
my consistent strategy? What he quotes
works against him. So he just quoted a
verse where it says that the head of
Christ is God. In the same verse it says
that the head of woman is man is the
husband. Does this mean that a woman is
not human? Does it have anything to do
with her nature? No. But it's talking
about role and authority. So the son
submitting to the father's authority has
nothing to do with his nature but his
role. Right? He's a perfect servant.
Which is why which is why which
[Applause]
is
hold knowledge.
All right. So the verses he's going to
is disproving him. So just because Jesus
submits to the father, it doesn't take
away from his nature. Just like woman
submits to her husband. That doesn't
mean she's not human like the husband
is. This is stupid. All right. 10
seconds. Okay. So going along with this,
the Bible continued to say that Jesus in
the form of God did not count equality
with God something to hold on to, but
made himself of no reputation.
You're quoting from Paul. You called it
Paul. Who called it? No. No. No. I
quoted to show you that Paul was not a
trinitarian. I'm asking you Jesus came
on the earth. He preached extensively.
He never said he's God. Never say he
worship me. He never say anybody
trinity.
You saw me. You saw me the word trinity.
I become a Christian. Show me the word.
The word Bible Christian fully fully
become Christian. But Christianity
Christianity is a religion. Jesus was a
Christian. In fact, Jesus wasn't sent to
you. Jesus said sheep of only the lost
sheep of the hands of Israel there.
Matthew 15:24. I mean, you're on and on.
You cannot prove anything. Look, you
read the Bible again. Let me go back.
Acts Acts 3:13. He said the God of
Abraham, the God of Isaac, the God of
Jacob, the God of our father glorified
his servant Jesus.
Empathic. Who is God? Who is a servant?
I mean, you're failing miserably with
me, bro. I'm going to go. You're wasting
my time. I knew. That's why I broke
£1,000 to challenge you because I know
time. You haven't studied your Bible.
Yeah, but I'm exposing you without the
money. Yeah, I know. But you can't prove
it. My
turn. This guy, man. Oh, yeah. Not on
me. Oh, hold it. Not on me.
Let me no my brother sister.
All right my brothers. All right. I'm
sorry.
After one more. So what do we keep
doing? He quotes a verse. I use the same
passage to refute him. The lame mean our
beautiful brother. He quoted Acts 13 or
3:13 where it says that he glorified his
servant Jesus. Two verses later it says
that you crucified the author of life.
[Applause]
Hey, real knowledge. Real knowledge.
Hey. Hey. Hey. Stay in that pot. Stay
there. So, hold on a second. So, the
servant of the father is the author of
life in the same passage, in the same
verses. So, the servant of the father is
still God. Wow. So it looks like the
verses you're bringing keeps on cooking
you mean. Okay. 10 seconds. 10 seconds.
Okay. So with that being said, please
let me explain why you have two
creators.
Time.
That's why I say you lie. Quote it. You
lie about quoting. You need to say
father
quote it.
Quote
it you want me to quote it as Oh that
God glorified his servant Jesus Christ.
No quote all of it. I'm quoting the
irrelevant verifies it verifies it. Let
me quote I'm not
afraid. I didn't call the I said I'm a h
of the Quran. No. Look here anywhere go
angle. I'm ready. You are studying my
Quran. Have you the Quran? Can I test
you? You already no come nonsense. Acts
13:3 said the God of Abraham, the God of
Isaac, the God of God of Jacob, the God
of our fathers glorified his servant
Jesus. Now, if Jesus is a servant, no,
I'm saying if Jesus servant of God, he
can be gone. I'm trying to debunk your
concept of trinity.
Um, yeah, pretty much. Now, that's why I
want two three minutes. Let's go another
5 minutes cuz I had so many. You're
wasting my time.
Has he stud his Bible? He's wasting my
time. Even the youngsters here, I bet on
you. The Christian
youth, even young Bob, young Bob can
quote this man. Has he studied the
Bible? Google any angle. I'm ready. Are
you ready to talk? Expose you going
down. Yeah. All right. So, I I thank you
for I guess repeating the verse but not
responding to what follows it. So, yes,
Jesus is a servant, but it says here as
you continue, it says, what does it say?
Lamine. Lamine. And you killed the
author of life. I mean, really quick,
who's the author of life?
Who's the author of life? Who's the
author of life? Okay. You know what?
author of life? Okay. So, you went to a
passage.
Jesus. Amen. Amen. All right. You guys
ready? All right. Cool. Selene, you went
to a a passage that proves that Jesus is
God, that he's the creator of life. He's
the source of all things. That's what
you went to. I can't believe it. Okay.
So, now I could deal with Jesus being
the creator because he's one in essence
with the father and the spirit. They are
God together. Now, why how can you deal
with Jesus also being a creator in Islam
if he's not God? Deal with it. You got
two gods. Deal with that. Deal with
that. Two creators.
Thank you.
It's too creative. I mean
40 creative means 30.
30 what? Oh, we're at 30 minutes. Yeah.
Oh, okay. Yeah. Last point. Do your do
your wrap up. This last point wrap up.
Yeah. Yeah.
312.
No. Hold on. S3. Hold on. I'm not him.
I'm looking for Look, Jesus, we are told
he's in heaven. No, I'm sorry. And there
stand and sitting at the right hand of
God. Almighty God, he said it now. Jesus
in heaven when he's supposed to be God
in a dream, too. But George, he said he
has a God. So Jesus in
heaven on the earth, he had a God. In
heaven has a God there. Yeah. Revelation
3:12. I want to read it. The one who is
victorious. The one who is victorious. I
will make a pillar in the temple of my
God. Never again will they leave it. I
will write on them the name of my God
and the name of the city of my God. The
new Jerusalem which is coming down out
of heaven for my God.
Jesus is heaven in in addition to John.
He doesn't even know when a Christian
read this one. He left Christianity. He
said he could understand when Jesus was
on the earth full of fully God, fully
man worshiping God, praying to God. But
in heaven, Jesus is saying he has a God.
Don't read that. Put that into context.
All right. Who is God in
heaven? No worries.
Easy answer. Jesus is in flesh still in
heaven. Because Jesus submits and take
on flesh. The father becomes his God in
that relationship. Not that he's a
separate god than the father, but that's
the relationship he has because he took
on flesh. Which is why Psalm 22, which
he quoted earlier, it says, "From my
mother's womb, you have been my God."
Not before. Now, let me get what does he
do? He quotes a passage. I show from the
same passage how it rebuked you. So,
from Revelation 3 going to verse 14, he
says, "These are the words of the amen,
the faithful, and the true witness, the
source of the creation of God."
Wait a second. A
mean. How How is Jesus the ruler, the
source, the arch of God's creation if
he's not God himself?
Answer from his own Bible. So to
answer any of my verses,
[Music]
you want to say anything from the Bible
from the Bible. Jesus said he has a God.
He was in the God. Give that. give you a
conclusion. You read the Bible. No,
coconut. You read the Bible again. Look
at this. Amazing. Jesus extensively make
I can't believe you study your Bible in
Luke Luke 6:12. Luke 6:12 that Jesus
went out into a mountain side to pray
and continued all night in prayer to
God. Who was he praying to? His father.
No, he said God. Yeah, his father. God.
Yeah, his father. Father is God. Yes.
And Jesus God on the earth. Jesus is
God. Yeah. I'm praying to you, Father.
How many are there? There's one
guy. He said Jesus on the earth. God is
God. I'm praying to God the father. So
God on the earth, God in heaven. How
many goes are there? One.
Before you go to America, Before you go
to America, I'll take you to mostly
hospital. Mostly hospital. Get back.
Go study your Bible. Still now. Go study
your Bible. Yeah. I've been for years
I've been doing it. You come to me.
Nobody. No. You got to hear my
conclusion.
You got me. You got Let me finish.
Conclusion. I'm not going. I want you to
hear. I want you to hear.
I want I want to hear it.
[Music]
Go. Yeah.
So, so here's the conclusion. So, here's
the conclusion. Okay, here's the
conclusion. So, the conclusion, guys,
Islam has two creators. The bird is
going to be thanking Allah and Jesus for
his existence. So, alhamdulillah for two
creators. No answer for that.
Alhamdulillah. Now, when it comes to
Jesus, now we see that Jesus submits to
the father. We see that Jesus is the
perfect servant who made himself of no
reputation but also has the form of God
and is the exact imprint of the father's
nature. Hebrews chapter 1:3. Every verse
he went to proved Jesus is God. He's the
source of God's creation. He's the
creator of all of all things. Through
him all things come and exist. And in
him we move out of our being. This is
it. Now we acknowledge. We acknowledge.
Yeah. Now hold on. Hold on. I'm not
done. I'm not done. I'm not done. Next
week he's coming here with Ju. I'm not
done making
I'm not done. J is coming here. He's
going to make Let me finish. The Holy
Spirit dec.
[Applause]
I didn't
finish. It's okay. It's okay. So, now
continuing. Notice I didn't finish. No,
I didn't finish. But it's okay. It's all
right. It's all right. It's all right.
That's right. Everybody listen up.
Everybody listen up. Everybody listen
up. Now, he talks about how Jesus is
praying to the father. You're saying
that God is communicating with God. God
is praying to God. God on earth is
talking to God in heaven. Uh yeah, this
is what we see in Isaiah. This is what
we see in uh Gen I don't even got to go
to Isaiah. In Genesis, we got Yahweh
speaking to Yahweh. Yahweh raised down
sulfur and fire on Sodom and Gomorrah
from Yahweh in heaven. Amen. So Yahweh
visited Abraham on earth and Yahweh
rained down Sodom and Gomorrah from
Yahweh in heaven. We also have in
Isaiah, he didn't respond to none of
this. In Isaiah, we got Yahweh being
sent by Yahweh and the spirit. So, three
persons of the Godhead. This is what we
see. So, yes, the New Testament is
consistent with what the Old Testament
preaches. The only outlier is the Quran.
Bye-bye Quran.
Hey man, thanks for coming. Watch your
hand. Your dog.
It's God. It's God. is God the
[Music]